This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“百分之二”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中坚韧不拔的科学、健身以及如何建立适应力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听“百分之二”。就是2%在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。在“回看”播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“回看”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的“艰难学习”。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极不安全但却必须进行的诚实对话，而你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士在交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“艰难学习”。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困之爱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“受困之爱”播客。大家好，欢迎回到你的二十岁心理学，这是一个讨论我们在二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变与过渡及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
为了我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，我们当然会一如既往地剖析二十岁的心理学。
Before we begin, I wanted to talk about my other podcast mantra for just a second. For those of you who don't know, this is actually not my only podcast. It might come as a little bit of a surprise, I don't think I talk about it nearly as much as I should, but I do have another show called mantra, where each Monday I talk about my mantra for the week and how I want it to essentially guide me. It is like the psychology of your 20s, but it's kind of more spiritual and philosophical,
在开始之前，我想花一点时间聊聊我的另一个播客“箴言”。对于那些不知道的人来说，这其实并不是我的唯一播客。这可能会有点让人意外，我觉得我谈论它的次数远远不够，但我确实还有另一个节目叫“箴言”，每周一我都会谈谈我本周的箴言，以及我想让它如何本质上引导我。它有点像二十岁的心理学，但它更偏向精神和哲学层面，
and it basically serves as a mental reset before you start your week, before you have to deal with work, with responsibilities, with family, friendship drama, whatever it is. So the episodes go for around 30 minutes and they include evidence-backed mental exercises for really powerful mindset shifts, journal prompts, a dive into wisdom from really great thinkers, plus also just like personal stories from me as well. And some of the mantras that I've done recently that I really, really like and that I think will resonate with you include things like,
它基本上可以作为一个精神重置，在你开始新的一周之前，在你不得不应对工作、责任、家庭、朋友间的抓马或是其他任何事情之前。所以每一集的时长大约是30分钟，其中包含有科学依据的心态练习，可以带来真正强大的心态转变，还有日记提示，对伟大思想家智慧的深入探讨，再加上我个人的故事。最近我做的一些我非常非常喜欢而且我认为会引起你们共鸣的箴言包括：
I allow myself to be happy with what I have. I make the best decisions with what I know now. And I know that love won't pass me. There's so many more. So this is my ask of you today. If you love the psychology of your 20s, give mantra a listen. Just try one episode, see what you think.
我允许自己对拥有的一切感到满足。我根据目前所知做出最佳决策。我知道爱不会与我擦肩而过。还有很多很多。所以我今天对你们的请求是：如果你喜欢二十岁的心理学，去听听“箴言”吧。只试听一集，看看你的感觉如何。
It is very much a passion project for me right now. So if you have feedback, if you have mantras that you think I should do, if you have a deep thought or dilemma that's been sitting heavy on your soul. I'd love to hear it. I'd love to cover it. So I'll leave a link in the episode description. But again, thank you so much for giving it a listen. Let's get back to the show and what we're talking about today.
目前这对我来说是一个非常充满热情的项目。所以如果你有反馈，如果你有你觉得我应该做的箴言，如果你有什么一直沉压在你心头深处的想法或困境。我很乐意倾听。我很乐意探讨它。所以我会在本集简介中留下一个链接。但再次感谢你们的聆听。让我们回到节目以及我们今天的话题。
Let me ask you a question. How many times a day do you think you say sorry? Five times? Ten times, maybe in nearly every single sentence. Sorry is. definitely one of the most important words in the human language. I think it is also one of the most overused. We say it constantly in emails, in texts, in relationships at work, when we cut someone off, when we speak up, when we take up space, even when we haven't done anything wrong, it becomes this
让我问你一个问题。你觉得你一天说多少次“对不起”？五次？十次，也许几乎在每一句话里。“对不起”绝对是人类语言中最最重要的词汇之一。我认为它也是被过度使用的词汇之一。我们在电子邮件、短信、恋爱关系、工作中，当我们打断别人时，当我们发声时，当我们占用空间时，甚至在我们什么都没做错的时候，都在不停地说它，它变成了
like automatic filler word for us, a stand in for like, please, for excuse me, for don't hate me. And for some of us, the word sorry is kind of part of who we are and how we present ourselves. It's almost protective. Like we say it constantly. And I think that reveals a lot about our insecurities, our fear, our conditioning. And it can also become, let's be real, completely exhausting. If I'm being honest, I used to do this all the time. I still catch myself doing it more than I'd like.
就像对我们来说一个自动的填充词，用来替代诸如“请”、“劳驾”、“别恨我”之类的词。对我们某些人来说，“对不起”这个词可以说是我们是谁以及我们如何展现自己的一部分。它几乎具有保护作用。就像我们不停地说它一样。我认为这暴露了我们的很多不安全感、恐惧和条件反射。而且说实话，这也可能变得筋疲力尽。老实说，我以前经常这样做。现在我发现自己比自己希望的更多时候还是会这样做。
Obviously, it's super normal to say sorry when, you do something wrong and you want to express genuine remorse. But I find that I say sorry in situations where it's not necessary. I'm not actually sorry. And in fact, someone else maybe even owes me an apology. This habit has a name. It's called Chronic Apologizing, the reflexive, often unconscious habit of saying sorry for things that don't require an apology.
很显然，当你做错了事并想表达真诚的懊悔时，说对不起是超级正常的。但我发现我在不必要的情况下也会说对不起。我其实并不是真的抱歉。事实上，可能别人还欠我一个道歉。这个习惯有个名字。它叫做“慢性道歉”，这是一种反射性的、通常是无意识的习惯，为那些并不需要道歉的事情说对不起。
And it is a pattern that many of us fall into. too. And for something so small and seemingly polite, chronic apologising can actually have a negative impact on our lives and a really negative impact on how we view ourselves and also how others view us. So in this episode, we are going to unpack all of it. What chronic apologising actually looks like, the psychological roots of this habit from attachment theory to early life experiences, how it changes how people see you in very strange ways that you probably don't know. And most importantly, I think, how we can break this cycle by actually rewriting our internal scripts for taking up space, for being authentic, for just simply existing, how we can change
这也是我们许多人都会陷入的模式。对于这样一个微不足道且看似礼貌的举动，慢性道歉实际上会对我们的生活产生负面影响，对我们如何看待自己以及别人如何看待我们产生非常负面的影响。所以在这一集中，我们将全面剖析这一切。慢性道歉实际上是什么样子的，这种习惯的心理学根源（从依恋理论到早期的生活经历），它是如何以你可能不知道的非常奇怪的方式改变别人对你的看法的。最重要的是，我认为，我们如何通过重写内在脚本来打破这个循环，从而坦然占用空间、保持真实、仅仅是简单地存在，我们如何改变
our internal scripts for expressing ourselves instead of. hiding behind this very innocuous, you know, self-preservation tool. So just like all of our episodes, this isn't about shaming. It's not to make you feel bad for doing something that probably feels second nature. It's about just understanding this habit and gaining some clarity and understanding why. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of chronic apologizing. Let's lay the groundwork to begin with. What do we actually mean when we say that someone is a chronic apologizer. Now, obviously, there is nothing wrong with a good genuine apology. Apologies are essential in relationships because they repair, they're humbling, they show compromise,
我们用来表达自己的内在脚本，而不是躲在那个非常无害的、你知道的自我保护工具后面。所以就像我们的所有节目一样，这不是为了羞辱。也不是为了让你因为做了一件感觉像是本能的事情而感到不好。这只是为了理解这个习惯，获得一些清晰度并理解原因。废话不多说，让我们进入慢性道歉的心理学。首先让我们奠定基础。当我们说一个人是“慢性道歉者”时，我们到底是什么意思？现在很明显，一个好的、真诚的道歉没有什么不对。道歉在人际关系中至关重要，因为它们能修复关系，让人变得谦卑，展现妥协，
but there is a difference between saying, I'm sorry, I sincerely accept that I have done the wrong thing, and just saying, oh, sorry I did this, sorry I did that, sorry as like a blanket statement for, please don't hate me. So a genuine apology has a few core ingredients. And an article from Harvard titled The Art of a Heartfelt Apology actually really lays this out. So they say that psychologically, a heartfelt apology has four main things. Firstly, it acknowledges that the offence took place and it takes responsibility for the offense. It explains what happened without excusing it. It expresses sincere remorse and it offers to make amends.
但说“对不起，我真诚地承认我做错了事”与仅仅说“哦，对不起我做了这个，对不起我做了那个，对不起”作为一种空洞的表态（意思就是请不要恨我）是有区别的。所以一个真诚的道歉有几个核心要素。哈佛大学发表的一篇名为《真诚道歉的艺术》的文章实际上对此进行了深入剖析。所以他们说，从心理学上讲，一个发自内心的道歉有四个主要方面。首先，它承认冒犯行为发生了，并为该冒犯承担责任。它在不找借口的情况下解释发生了什么。它表达真诚的懊悔，并提出弥补措施。
For example, a sincere apology is something like, I'm sorry I was late, I acknowledge I'm late, traffic was insane, but I should have left earlier, and it won't happen again. That's good, that's taking ownership, and when you actually then end up doing something on your promise to not let it happen again, that's even better. But when you're apologising constantly for just existing, for speaking, for needing things, it starts to become something that is a skeleton of that. And at its core, chronic apologising, it's basically when we say sorry so frequently that it begins to lose its meaning and that it becomes a reflex. So think of it almost like a filler word. So just a normal sentence like, can I just say something quickly? We have to begin with, sorry, can I just say something quickly before you even said the thing? Am I bothering you?
例如，真诚的道歉类似于：对不起我迟到了，我承认我迟到了，交通太疯狂了，但我本该早点出门的，而且这不会再发生了。这很好，这是在承担责任，而当你最终兑现承诺不再让它发生时，那就更好了。但当你为了仅仅存在、为了说话、为了有需求而不断道歉时，它就开始变成那种行为的空壳。它的核心在于，慢性道歉基本上就是当我们频繁地说对不起，以至于它开始失去意义，变成了一种条件反射。所以可以把它想象成一个填充词。就像一句普通的句子：我能快速说件事吗？我们必须以“对不起，在你甚至还没开口之前我能快速说件事吗？我在打扰你吗？”开头。
Sorry, am I bothering you? I didn't mean to take up so much time. Sorry, I didn't mean to take up so much time. Can I just grab that item? Sorry, can I just grab that item? It's this like word that we place in front of all sentences where we're asking permission, almost to kind of say to someone, I don't mean to cause offense, don't come and bite my head off. And it's such a knee-jerk reaction.
“对不起，我在打扰你吗？我不是故意占用那么多时间的。对不起，我不是故意占用那么多时间的。我能拿一下那个东西吗？对不起，我能拿一下那个东西吗？”这个词就像是被我们放在所有要求允许的句子的前面，几乎是为了对某人说：“我无意冒犯，别来咬我。”这真是一种膝跳反射式的反应。
And often we do it because we feel like we aren't actually allowed to take up space. We feel like sorry is a way. for us to make ourselves smaller and more palatable and, you know, more tasteful to other people. It's a verbal filler. And here's the kicker. This constant apologizing, it's often more for us, actually, than it is for other people. We think that it's about making other people happy. Really, it's about managing our own discomfort around how we think that people will see us. And so sorry actually becomes a very deeply ingrained internal strategy to manage our own anxiety, discomfort, or fear of disapproval. Essentially what we're trying to do when we say
而且我们经常这样做，是因为我们觉得自己其实不允许占用空间。我们觉得说对不起是一种方式，能让我们把自己变得更小、更容易被接受，你知道的，对其他人来说更有品味。它是一个语言填充词。最关键的是。这种不断的道歉，其实更多是为了我们自己，而不是为了别人。我们以为这是为了让别人开心。实际上，这是为了管理我们自己对于别人会如何看我们的不安感。所以“对不起”实际上变成了一种根深蒂固的内部策略，用来管理我们自己的焦虑、不安或对不赞同的恐惧。本质上我们在说
sorry before any sentence is we're trying to control how we're perceived. We're trying to soften our presence or to preemptively diffuse any potential negative reaction even if that reaction only exists in our minds. And it's essentially a mechanism to allow us to feel like we are controlling how other people see us. And we're controlling that narrative in a way that makes people not see us as a threat. So whilst it is directed at someone else, the true function often lies in our own internal emotional landscape and the fact that we cannot deal or manage the idea of someone seeing us differently to how we want to be perceived, being mad at us, being frustrated, or not liking us.
在任何句子之前说“对不起”，我们是在试图控制自己被感知的方式。我们试图缓和我们的存在，或者先发制人地化解任何潜在的负面反应，即使这种反应只存在于我们的脑海中。这本质上是一种机制，让我们觉得自己正在掌控别人如何看待我们。我们在以一种不让别人把我们视为威胁的方式掌控这种叙事。因此，虽然它是针对别人的，但真正的功能往往在于我们自己的内部情感图景，以及我们无法处理或管理这样一种想法：别人看待我们的方式与我们希望被感知的方式不同，别人对我们生气、沮丧或不喜欢我们。
You know, this is not just a random habit. It's not just like a funny thing. There are deep psychological roots here, and many theories will point to early childhood experiences and the messages that we internalized about our worth, our safety, and our relationships very early on. One key concept here is self-worth. If you grew up in an environment where you felt like you constantly had to earn love or approval, or maybe where expressing yourself led to criticism, invalidation, punishment,
你知道，这不仅仅是一个随意的习惯。这不仅仅是一件有趣的事情。这里有着深刻的心理学根源，许多理论都将原因指向早期的童年经历，以及我们在很早的时候对自己的价值、安全感和人际关系所内化的信息。这里的一个关键概念是自尊。如果你在一个环境中长大，觉得你不断需要赢得爱或认可，或者表达自己会导致批评、否定、惩罚，
you may have possibly learned that being small, accommodating, unassuming was the safest path. Apologizing almost became a way to shrink yourself, to make yourself less of a target, especially if, you know, you had parents or family members who were voluntary. who were violent or if you were in a big family. The way that we saw this as a child was if I apologize before they get the chance to be upset with me, maybe they will accept me as I am rather than need to find something wrong or rather than needing to find something to attack me for. You're somewhat at their mercy when you're a child, right?
你可能已经学会了保持渺小、迁就、不引人注目是最安全的道路。道歉几乎成了一种缩小自己、让自己少成为一个目标的途径，尤其是如果你（你知道的）有经常发脾气、有暴力的父母或家人，或者如果你在一个大家庭里。我们作为孩子对此的看法是：如果我在他们有机会对我不满之前道歉，也许他们会按原样接受我，而不是需要找出什么毛病来，或者而不是需要找什么借口来攻击我。当你还是个孩子的时候，你在某种程度上任由他们摆布，对吧？
You're at the mercy of your parents, of older family members, of older siblings, and so this becomes part of the armor. This is also, of course, a classic pattern of people pleasing, which we've discussed on the podcast before, probably like three years ago now if you want to listen to that episode. But another major contributor to that people pleasing, apologizing, shrinking cycle is also anxiety. For those of us with high levels of anxiety, especially social anxiety, apologize. is a way, again, to control the interaction, but also it's a form of safety-seeking behavior. So this refers to actions that we take to try and relieve some of our anxiety, specifically around things that we see as a threat. So if you are someone who is naturally, socially anxious and you see interacting with other people as very scary and, you know, anxiety-inducing and freak-inducing and freak. this sorry technique almost becomes a self-soother. Yes, there is the example we gave before of it being a way
你任由父母、年长的家庭成员、年长的兄弟姐妹摆布，所以这成了盔甲的一部分。当然，这也是讨好型人格的经典模式，我们以前在播客中讨论过，如果你想听那一集的话，大概是三年前了。但导致讨好型人格、道歉、自我缩小循环的另一个主要因素也是焦虑。对于我们这些有着高水平焦虑的人来说，尤其是社交焦虑，道歉是一种再次控制互动的方式，但它也是一种寻求安全的行为形式。这指的是我们为了缓解某些焦虑而采取的行动，特别是围绕着我们视为威胁的事情。因此，如果你是一个天生有社交焦虑并且认为与他人互动非常可怕、会引起焦虑和惊恐的人，
to control how someone sees you and that making you feel calm, but also even though you know your sorries may not be doing anything, for you it feels like this nice thing you can return to that feels safe and feels calm and almost becomes a ritual. Saying sorry before every sentence means that you can get the words out, means that you feel more prepared. However, as much as we hope that a sorry is going to diffuse our anxiety, research does actually suggest the opposite. The 2009 study published by Cambridge University actually suggests that these kinds of safety-seeking, anxious apologies actually serve as anxiety maintenance.
这种道歉技巧几乎成了一种自我安抚。是的，我们之前给出了一个例子，说它是控制别人如何看你的一种方式，能让你感到平静，但同时，尽管你知道你的道歉可能什么也没做，但对你来说，它感觉像是一个你可以回归的美好事物，感觉安全、平静，几乎变成了一种仪式。在每句话之前说对不起意味着你可以把话说出口，意味着你感觉准备得更充分。然而，尽管我们希望一句对不起能化解我们的焦虑，但研究实际上表明事实恰恰相反。剑桥大学2009年发表的一项研究实际上表明，这种寻求安全的焦虑道歉实际上起到了维持焦虑的作用。
They bring us a sense of relief in the moment. but they keep the anxiety cycle going and they negatively reinforce what we're feeling. So in the moment, you're getting the fleeting relief from the anxiety because the perceived reward, the removal of an unpleasant feeling is making you feel better, but it also means that we never actually confront the possibility of not saying sorry and of people not liking us and of social situations not going well and realizing that we are still very capable in those situations. A lot of our fear is maintained by never actually experiencing the thing that we're scared of. But if we were to be put in a situation where we didn't say sorry and someone was mad at us,
它们在当下给我们带来了一种解脱感，但它们让焦虑循环持续下去，并对我们的感受起到了负面强化作用。所以在当下，你从焦虑中获得了短暂的解脱，因为感知到的回报（消除了不愉快的感受）让你感觉好多了，但这同时也意味着我们从未真正去面对不去说对不起的可能性，不去面对别人不喜欢我们的可能性，不去面对社交场合进展不顺利但我们依然能在这些场合中游刃有余的可能性。我们的许多恐惧都是因为从未真正经历过我们害怕的事情而得以维持的。但是，如果我们被置于一个不说对不起而且有人对我们生气的境地，
we may just realize, you know, that isn't the end of the world. Like we aren't going to die because of that. Someone not liking us is actually sometimes not even our problem. Now, whilst chronic apologising is predominantly rooted in anxiety and people pleasing in early life experiences, It's also worth noting a more specific, albeit less common overlap. In some very rare instances, excessive apologizing might actually take on a compulsive quality, hinting it like a very deep connection to OCD, obsessive-compulsive disorder. So that thing I was talking about before where you say sorry as a habit, you say sorry almost as a ritual, you say sorry because you can't imagine not saying sorry,
我们可能会意识到，这其实并不是世界末日。就像我们不会因此而死一样。别人不喜欢我们，实际上有时甚至根本不是我们的问题。现在，虽然习惯性道歉主要根源于焦虑、讨好型人格以及早年生活经历，但同样值得注意的是一种更具体、尽管不那么常见的重叠。在某些非常罕见的情况下，过度道歉实际上可能会带有一种强迫性的特质，暗示着它与强迫症（OCD，强迫性障碍）之间存在着非常深厚的联系。所以，我刚才说的习惯性地说对不起，几乎像是一种仪式一样地说对不起，因为你无法想象不说道歉而说对不起，
you think that something bad's going to happen if you don't do it. For someone with OCD, that's what we would call a compulsion. A repetitive, mental or behavioral act performed in response to a very intrusive, painful, distressing thought and obsession. And we perform the compulsion as a way to reduce or prevent a dreaded outcome. So, for example, if someone has an obsession about being terribly rude and not having realized it and someone being mad at them, they might engage in excessive checking rituals that include repetitive apologies as a way to stop themselves from feeling so anxious about this thing coming
你会觉得如果你不这样做，就会发生什么不好的事情。对于患有强迫症的人来说，这就是我们所谓的强迫行为。一种重复性的、精神上的或行为上的动作，是为了应对某种非常具有侵入性的、痛苦的、令人苦恼的想法（即强迫观念）而执行的。我们执行强迫行为是为了减少或防止可怕的结果。因此，比方说，如果有人有一种强迫观念，担心自己极其粗鲁却没有意识到，并且担心别人会生气，他们可能会进行过度检查的仪式，包括重复道歉，以此来阻止自己对这种即将发生的事情感到那么焦虑。
true. There's no logical reason behind it. We know that saying sorry repetitively might not actually change anything, but because it is driven by this very strong urge to neutralize a negative thought, it feels like we can't stop ourselves. If you're apologizing maybe feels like less than a general habit and more like an uncontrollable ritual tied to a specific distressing situation or belief or thought that something terrible is going to happen, this might be something that a mental health professional could use to differentiate between a chronic apologizer who is just anxious and someone who has OCD and who this chronic apologizing may be a symptom of. Let's talk about a few other explanations here, one of them being social learning theory.
这背后没有任何逻辑原因。我们知道，重复说对不起可能并不能真正改变什么，但由于它是由这种极强的冲动所驱动的——为了中和负面想法，感觉自己无法控制。如果你道歉的感觉可能更少是一种普遍习惯，而更像是一种无法控制的仪式，与某种特定的痛苦处境、信念或“会有可怕事情发生”的想法紧密相连，这或许可以成为心理健康专业人士区分“单纯焦虑的慢性道歉者”与“患有强迫症且慢性道歉可能是其症状之一的人”的一个依据。我们来谈谈这里的其他几种解释，其中之一就是社会学习理论。
So obviously we can pick up apologizing as a habit when we realize that it tends to make people less frustrated at us. And if that was the childhood and family environment we grew up in, that becomes a strategy through that means as a way to stop someone from being critical of you, as a way. to deal with an inconsistent or unpredictable caregiver response or a family response and to deal with disapproval and rejection in a family unit. There's another way that this is impressed upon us as well. And it's through social learning theory where basically if we observe our parents apologizing
所以很明显，当我们发现道歉往往能让别人对我们的挫败感减少时，我们就会把道歉当作一种习惯来养成。如果那是我们成长的童年和家庭环境，这就成了一种策略，用它来阻止别人对你进行批判，作为一种应对不一致或不可预测的照顾者反应或家庭反应的方法，以及应对家庭单元中不赞同和拒绝的方法。还有另一种方式将这一点深深烙印在我们身上。那就是通过社会学习理论，基本上，如果我们观察到父母频繁地道歉，
a lot, we tend to imitate that. If you had a parent or a significant adult in your life, who was a chronic apologizer, constantly saying sorry for minor infractions or even for their mere presence, sometimes you simply pick up on that habit by being close to them and you internalize it as a normal way of communicating, completely unaware of its underlying psychological impact. You know, you saw it, so you did it. And people will often say that this really comes down to their mothers
我们往往会模仿这种行为。如果你的生命中有一个父母或重要的成年人是一个习惯性道歉的人，经常为微小的违规甚至仅仅因为自己的存在而不断说对不起，有时你只要通过靠近他们就会染上这个习惯，并将其内化为一种正常的沟通方式，完全没有意识到它背后的心理影响。你知道，你看到了，所以你就做了。人们通常会说，这真的归咎于他们的母亲，
and how their mothers treated the outside world or were treated by, their fathers were betrayed by other people. oftentimes like it's our moms who are the ones who are made to feel very small and the ones who apologize constantly if they're not confident if they aren't typically outspoken and we see that especially if you're a woman you see how your mom responded to the environment and to the patriarchy and you start doing that yourself and you don't really understand it until perhaps a partner calls you out on it or a friend starts to call you out on it and says, hey, like, you don't need to say sorry for that, but because you saw how your mother or a parent gained reassurance through excessive
以及他们的母亲是如何对待外部世界的，或者她们是如何被父亲对待的、被其他人背叛的。通常情况下，就像我们的母亲是那些被弄得觉得自己非常渺小的人，是那些如果不自信、通常不直言不讳就会不断道歉的人，我们看到了这一点，特别是如果你是一个女性，你看到你的母亲是如何对环境和父权制作出反应的，然后你开始自己也这样做，而且你并不真正理解它，直到有一天一个伴侣或朋友开始指出这一点并说：“嘿，你不需要为此道歉”，但因为你看到你的母亲或某位长辈如何通过过度道歉来获得安心，
apologizing and how perhaps a parent or someone else in your life used sorries as a way to remain vigilant over potential threats, you just can't avoid doing it. You can't avoid it. I think a lot of this can really be nicely explained by the fawn response, which we talked about on an episode a few weeks back on emotionally immature parents. But as a refresher, if you didn't listen to that episode, fawning is basically a recent addition to the fight, flight, or freeze response that we all know about. Fight, flight and freeze, basically an inbuilt way of responding to danger
以及一个长辈或你生活中的某个人如何将“对不起”作为对潜在威胁保持警惕的一种方式，你就是无法避免这样做。你无法避免它。我认为，很多这方面的原因都可以很好地用“讨好反应”（fawn response）来解释，我们在几周前关于情感不成熟父母的那期节目中讨论过这个概念。但作为复习，如果你没有听过那一期节目，“讨好”基本上是战斗、逃跑或冻结反应之外最近新加入的一种反应机制，这些反应都是我们所熟知的。战斗、逃跑和冻结，基本上是应对危险的内置反应方式，
and how we go about surviving that danger. but recently researchers have really identified another form of survival, which is to make friends with the danger, to make friends with the threat. This is a really weird analogy, but if you've ever watched a nature documentary with pack animals, you might see how wolves or coyotes they fawn the alpha. They lick them, they almost bow down to them,
以及我们如何在这个危险中生存下来。但最近研究人员确实识别出了另一种生存形式，那就是与危险交朋友，与威胁交朋友。这是一个非常奇怪的比喻，如果你看过关于群居动物的自然纪录片，你可能会看到狼或郊狼是如何讨好头狼的。它们舔舐它们，几乎向它们顶礼膜拜，
as a way of basically saying, you know, no need to dominate over me, like, I'm already letting you. You don't need to teach me the hard way. I get it already. Forning is a way of surviving, a very deeply entrenched way of surviving by prioritizing others' needs and feelings to maintain your own safety. In childhood, for you, this may have looked like being the good kid who never caused trouble, who always agreed, quickly apologize for anything that upset a teacher or a parent. You learned that you were safest. when you made friends with the potential individual who might harm you either emotionally or physically. And this becomes this underlying message throughout our life.
基本上是在说：“你知道的，不需要压制我，就像，我已经向你屈服了。你不需要用严厉的方式来教训我。我已经懂了。”讨好是一种生存方式，一种深深植根于生存的方式，通过优先考虑别人的需求和感受来维持你自己的安全。在童年中，对你来说，这可能表现为做一个从不惹麻烦、总是赞同、对惹恼老师或父母的任何事情都迅速道歉的好孩子。你了解到，当你与可能在情感或身体上伤害你的潜在个人交朋友时，你是最安全的。这成为贯穿我们一生的潜在信息。
I'm only safe if I am agreeable. My needs are less important than yours. I must not upset the balance. And this is really what we're doing this entire time. We're fawning, whether it is because of a safety-seeking scenario whether it is to reduce our anxiety around being perceived strangely, whether it is OCD, whether it is learnt. What we are trying to do is say, don't hurt me, I am not someone that you need to be mad at. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, we're going to explore why this may have such an impact on us in our 20s.
只有当我讨人喜欢时我才是安全的。我的需求比你的需求更不重要。我绝不能打破平衡。这确实是我们一直在做的事情。我们在讨好，无论是出于寻求安全的场景，还是为了减少我们因被奇怪看待而产生的焦虑，无论是由于强迫症，还是由于习得的行为。我们试图做的是说：别伤害我，我不是一个需要你对之生气的人。好吧，我们要休息一下，但当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么这会对我们二十多岁的年龄段产生如此大的影响。
And finally, how we can start to undo this very deeply ingrained habit. So stay with us. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
最后，我们将探讨如何开始改掉这个根深蒂固的习惯。所以请继续收听。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主宰健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字是 T-W-O-Persent，可在 I-Hart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit. by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说要相信你的好姐妹。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女朋友们》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。可在 I-heart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈 80 年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
需要明确的是，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在任何一天谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条红线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》（难走的路），我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness, this month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're freed?
为了响应心理健康意识月，这个月我将把我自己在心理健康领域超过十年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这里做一个好人很重要，还是因为你获得了自由才成为一个好人？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，由我卡尔·盖恩斯带你一起，围绕疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Let's turn our attention specifically to how this plays out in our 20s. This is obviously a decade of intense growth, of self-discovery, of building very foundational adult relationships and careers. Chronic apologizing, when it's pervasive and ingrained, can impact us in those really critical areas. Firstly, it significantly impacts our relationships.
搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。让我们把注意力专门转向这种行为在我们二十多岁时是如何表现的。这显然是一个充满激烈成长、自我发现以及建立极其基础的成人关系和职业的十年。习惯性道歉，当它无孔不入且根深蒂固时，会真正对我们这些关键领域产生影响。首先，它会极大地影响我们的人际关系。
And I'm talking about all relationships here, not just romantic partnerships, but friendships, family, even the connection that you have with yourself. A massive part of this is because it can act as a way that blurs boundaries. When you constantly apologize, you're essentially sending a subtle, often unconscious message to others that your needs, opinions, even your mere presence, are secondary to their comfort. This, of course, makes it incredibly difficult to set healthy boundaries. For instance, if you apologize for saying no to an invitation or for expressing a preference in a group decision, you are inadvertently teaching others that they can push back,
我这里指的是所有关系，不仅仅是浪漫伴侣关系，还有友谊、家庭，甚至是你与自己的内在连接。这其中很大一部分原因是因为它可以充当模糊界限的方式。当你不断道歉时，你实际上是在向他人发送一个微妙的、通常是无意识的信息，即你的需求、观点，甚至仅仅是你的存在，都是次要的，要为他们的舒适让路。这当然会使建立健康的界限变得极其困难。例如，如果你因为拒绝邀请或在集体决定中表达个人偏好而道歉，你就是在无意中教导他人他们可以反推，
that your boundaries are negotiable, or that you feel guilty for having them. You know, most people who love you and who care about you, they won't push that. They will respect what you want, and they will respect your decision. But God forbid you encounter someone who wants something from you that you don't want to give them, or who is naturally manipulative. Manipulative. manipulative people are incredibly socially aware and they can see this habit and use it against you. They know that saying sorry often means I feel guilty for what I'm saying. I feel guilty for letting you down. And so if they just push that button a few more times, maybe you'll give in.
你的界限是可以商量的，或者你为拥有这些界限而感到内疚。你知道，大多数爱你并且关心你的人，他们不会那样做。他们会尊重你的意愿，尊重你的决定。但怕就怕你遇到一个想要从你这里得到你不想给的东西，或者天生具有操纵性的人。操纵性极强的人具有极高的社会洞察力，他们能看出这个习惯并将其作为对付你的武器。他们知道说“对不起”通常意味着：我为我所说的话感到内疚。我为让你失望感到内疚。因此，如果他们多按几次这个按钮，也许你就会屈服。
This dynamic is particularly interesting when we look at gender differences in communication styles. Research by linguists and social psychologists have explored how women are often use apologies and other softening language more frequently than men, sometimes as a way to maintain rapport or to avoid perceived aggression. And whilst this can be a really valuable social tool in some contexts, you know, trying to avoid aggravating someone, trying to tone down potentially volatile situations, when it becomes chronic and across different contexts, it can inadvertently diminish our assertiveness. It makes it harder to be perceived, as someone with clear non-negotiable boundaries,
当我们审视沟通风格中的性别差异时，这种动态尤其有趣。语言学家和小社会心理学家进行的研究探讨了女性如何比男性更频繁地使用道歉和其他缓和语气的语言，有时是为了维持融洽的关系或避免被视为具有攻击性。虽然在某些情况下这可能是一种非常有价值的社交工具，比如试图避免激化矛盾、试图淡化潜在的不稳定局势，但当它变成慢性且跨越不同情境时，它会无意中削弱我们的自信。这使得我们更难被视为一个拥有明确、不容妥协界限的人，
and that leads to feelings of resentment or being taken advantage of. It means that we don't feel like we can be assertive anymore, that we don't have the voice for that. A study published in 2010, it was published in psychological sciences, it found that women tend to apologize more than men, not just because they've necessarily done more things wrong, but because often we perceive our behavior, in public settings as inherently offensive or intrusive.
这会导致怨恨情绪的产生，或者觉得自己被占了便宜。这意味着我们不再觉得自己可以自信地表达，我们不再拥有为此发声的底气。2010 年发表在《心理科学》杂志上的一项研究发现，女性往往比男性道歉更多，这不仅是因为她们做错了更多的事情，还因为通常我们在公共场合会将自己的行为视为天生具有冒犯性或侵入性的。
We feel like me existing, me being loud, that's not palatable. That's not enjoyable. People don't want to hear from me. And this can have huge implications in terms of how willing we are to speak up for ourselves when a partner hurts our feelings, when a friend crosses the line, when our parents or our boss doesn't respect our boundaries. If every statement is prefaced with sorry or every opinion is softened by an apology, your voice to you starts to feel like it's losing its power.
我们觉得我的存在、我的大声说话是无法被接受的。是不讨人喜欢的。人们不想听到我说话。这会对我们为自己发声的意愿产生巨大的影响——当伴侣伤害了我们的感情时，当朋友越界时，当我们的父母或老板不尊重我们的界限时。如果每一句话都以“对不起”开头，或者每一个观点都由一个道歉来软化，那么对你自己而言，你的声音开始觉得它正在失去力量。
This isn't just about how others see you. This is how you hear yourself. Your internal voice begins to mirror your external one, reinforcing the idea that your thoughts and your feelings, they aren't valid and less cushioned by an apology. And that can even mean that when we're going to even mean that when we're going to be a question, we're just thinking private thoughts to ourselves, like, oh, I would really like to do that, or I would really like to achieve that thing, or I think I really deserve to be treated better, this other part of us goes, no, no, you're not. Drink down, stay small, don't make a fuss. That
这不仅仅关乎别人如何看待你。这关乎你如何听到自己的声音。你的内心独白开始模仿你的外在表达，从而强化这样一种观念：你的思想和感受是无效的，除非加上道歉作为缓冲。这甚至可能意味着，当我们甚至可能意味着当我们思考一个问题时，我们只是在心里默默地想，比如“哦，我真的很想做那个”或者“我真的很想实现那个目标”或者“我觉得我真的值得被更好对待”，我们内心的另一部分就会说：“不，不，你不配。降低姿态，保持渺小，别大惊小怪。”那个
part of you that has been pleasing others really starts to enforce some very strong and harsh rules upon what you think you can ask of yourself and what you think you deserve, which is when we start to self-abandon is when we start to say, oh yeah, I don't deserve that thing, even though no one has told you that you don't deserve it, or no, I shouldn't ask for anything else, even though, you know, the universe isn't greedy, the universe has a lot to give. People want to give you things. They want to be kind to you. I've often found with my friends who apologize a lot and who don't really ask for things, I'm like waiting for them to ask me for something.
一直以来都在讨好别人的你内心的一部分，开始对你认为你可以对自己的要求以及你认为自己配得上什么，强加一些非常严格和严厉的规则，这就是我们开始自我抛弃的时候，这就是我们开始说：“哦，是的，我不配得到那个东西”，尽管没有人告诉你你不配，或者“不，我不应该要求任何其他东西”，尽管，你知道，宇宙并不贪婪，宇宙有很多东西可以给予。人们想要把东西送给你。他们想要对你善良。我经常发现，我那些经常道歉、不怎么主动提要求的朋，我其实都在等他们向我开口请求什么。
Like, my sister is someone who is like this and she never asks for anything from anybody. And the moments that she does, I'm so excited by it because someone who loves you and who cares about you, like wants to be able to reassure you and validate you and wants to be able to give. Ironically, despite best intentions, and I debated whether to talk about this, but I think it's important. Chronic apologising can actually create a lot of distance within relationships. you know, think about it. If we're not really expressing what we think and we feel, we're not letting ourselves be authentic,
比如，我的姐姐就是这样一个人，她从不向任何人索取任何东西。每当她破例提出要求时，我都会感到非常兴奋，因为一个爱你、关心你的人，其实是渴望去安慰你、认同你并给予你爱与支持的。讽刺的是，尽管我们的初衷是好的——我曾纠结过要不要谈这个话题，但我认为它真的很重要——习惯性道歉实际上会在人际关系中造成极大的疏离感。你想想看，如果我们没有真正表达自己的想法和感受，没有展现真实的自我，
it means that someone doesn't really know how to love us better. There's not really a genuine connection there that's built on self-expression and vulnerability because you are showing up as someone in this relationship who isn't really you. You're showing up as the person that you think someone else wants you to be. And so this person can't really get to know you. Like there's a wall.
这就意味着别人根本不知道该如何更好地去爱我们。由于你展现出的并非真实的自我，而是一个你认为别人希望你成为的人，因此这种建立在自我表达和脆弱感之上的真挚连接便不复存在。你扮演的是别人眼中的你，所以对方根本无法真正了解你。这就好像你们之间隔了一堵墙。
There is a layer that they're never going to crack. And that can make it really hard to grow together, especially if there is a constant need to appease them. Sometimes they can also be a frustration of like, stop thinking only about me and let me think about you. That can make them feel like maybe you don't trust them. That can make them feel like maybe you think you need to make yourself smaller for them, that they're a bad partner.
你们之间永远隔着一层无法打破的隔膜。这会使双方很难共同成长，尤其是当你 constamment 表现出迎合对方的需要时。有时，这甚至会引发一种挫败感，比如：“别总想着我，让我来想想你吧。” 这会让他们觉得，也许你并不信任他们；或者让你觉得，自己必须在对方面前贬低自己，仿佛他们是一个糟糕的伴侣。
In professional settings as well, excessive apologizing, you know, can inadvertently signal a lack of confidence, a lack of competence. It can kind of subtly undermine your presence in meetings, in the workplace, at lunches, in professional settings. Basically, because you send a signal to others that you don't trust yourself and that you feel like an imposition. So perhaps they start to see it your way. They start to say, well, if that person believes that they are useless
在职场环境中也是如此，过度道歉往往会在无意中释放出缺乏自信、缺乏能力的信号。它会在会议、职场、午餐以及各种职业场合中，潜移默化地削弱你的存在感。基本上，这是因为你向他人传递了一个信号：你不信任自己，并且觉得自己是在麻烦别人。于是，对方可能也会开始认同你的看法。他们会想：既然这个人觉得自己一无是处，
and that what they're saying is annoying or frustrating, well, maybe what they think about themselves is right, and I should start to think about them that way as well. A 2010 study actually found that, you know, uncertain language, apologetic language can really diminish your perceived authority, but it can also make you come off as insincereal. and it can mean that people trust you less. So the paradox of chronic apologizing is that we do it to make other people happy
而且觉得她说的话很烦人、很让人沮丧，那也许她对自己的看法是对的，我也应该开始这样看待她。2010年的一项研究实际上发现，不确定的语言和充满歉意的语言不仅会大大削弱你给别人带来的权威感，还会让你显得不够真诚，从而导致别人对你的信任度降低。因此，习惯性道歉的悖论在于，我们这样做是为了让别人开心，
and we do it to make our anxiety less in the face of other people and around other people. But actually it leads to the opposite outcomes. It makes you feel less seen, makes people value you less and it makes you more isolated. It's a survival strategy that ultimately. we do have to find a way around. We have to find a way around this idea that we have to be small, that we have to be nice, that we have to be kind and appealing and appeasing in order to get what we want. So now that we know why this happens, now that we understand the consequences, let's really attempt to rewire this automatic response and build a new healthier one.
是为了在面对他人或身处人群时减轻自己的焦虑。但实际上，它却带来了截然相反的结果。它会让你觉得更少被看见，让别人对你的价值打折扣，并使你变得更加孤立。这是一种生存策略，但我们终究得找到一条出路。我们必须打破这种观念：为了得到想要的东西，我们就必须变得卑微、必须表现得讨喜、善良、有吸引力并且一味迎合。所以，既然我们知道了这一切发生的原因，也理解了其带来的后果，那就让我们真正尝试去重塑这种自动反应，建立一种更健康的新习惯。
This definitely takes patience. Most important, it takes a lot of self-compassion. There is no shame in chronic apologising. There is no embarrassment to it. How other people see you as a result of this or as a result of not doing this is actually not your problem, but let's find a way to rewire it for you so that you feel like you're taking up less space and perhaps just less exhausted from constantly needing to be protecting yourself in this way. The first and arguably most crucial stuble, is simply noticing it. You know, you cannot change what you are not aware of. So identify your triggers. Start paying attention to when you apologize. Is it with certain people, a certain kind of
这绝对需要耐心。最重要的是，它需要大量的自我同情。习惯性道歉并不丢脸，也没什么好尴尬的。因为这样做或不这样做而导致别人如何看待你，其实根本不是你的问题。但让我们为你找到一种重塑它的方法，好让你觉得占用的空间变小了，或许也不至于因为总得这样保护自己而感到筋疲力尽。第一步，也是可以说最关键的一步，就是去注意到它。你知道的，你无法改变你所没有意识到事物的。所以，找出你的触发点。开始留心你在什么时候会道歉。是面对特定的人、某种特定类型的人、
person, specific situations? Is it when you're feeling a particular emotion like insecurity or a fear of judgment? Maybe you notice it more when you're asking for something or when you're expressing a differing opinion compared to neutral situations. It's particularly important to notice if it's around certain people, because that's going to really, I think, factor into your assessment as to whether you are your most unique, authentic version of you with these people and whether perhaps they're not the most well suited to be in your life. Next, I want you to really challenge your automatic thoughts. As we've said already in this episode, this is a habit. This is a habit. This is a habit that has been built on the fact that apologizing has brought you some kind of relief or some
还是在特定的情境下？是不是当你感受到某种特定情绪（比如没有安全感或害怕被评判）时？也许当你开口请求帮助，或者在面对中立情况表达不同意见时，你会更频繁地注意到这一点。注意到它是否只针对某些人尤为重要，因为我认为这会直接影响你的评估：你在这些人面前是不是最独特、最真实的自己，以及他们或许根本不是最适合出现在你生命中的人。接下来，我希望你真正去挑战自己的自动思维。正如我们在本集前面已经说过的那样，这是一种习惯。这是一种习惯，这种习惯之所以养成，是因为道歉曾带给你某种程度的解脱或某种
kind of pleasant feeling, even if that pleasant feeling is the removal of a negative feeling. So once you start noticing the habit, you have to begin to question the thoughts that fuel it. To do this, we really want to start to question why we feel the need to apologize. When you catch yourself mid-apology, ask yourself, what am I really apologizing for here? Is anyone really that bad at me? Did I really do anything that bad? Am I really sorry? Is the thing that I feel sorry for actually something that I should feel sorry for?
愉悦感，哪怕这种愉悦感仅仅是消除了某种负面情绪。因此，一旦你开始注意到这个习惯，你就必须开始质疑那些助长它的想法。为了做到这一点，我们真正要做的是开始反思：为什么我们觉得有必要道歉？当你发现自己正在道歉时，问问自己：“我在这里到底在为什么道歉？真的有人在生我的气吗？我真的做了什么很糟糕的事吗？我是真的感到抱歉吗？我感到抱歉的这件事，真的是我应该感到抱歉的吗？”
Or if I just asked for something that I needed? Have I just existed? Have I just been human? Challenge the assumption that you are constantly doing things wrong? And ask yourself, if someone else did this thing, would I feel like they needed to apologize for it? Because the answer is often, 100% no but we are much harsher and much more severe as critics when it comes to ourselves. If you're apologizing to avoid a negative reaction, ask yourself, what's the worst realistic
还是说，我只是在索取我需要的东西？我只是在正常生活？我只是作为一个普通人在活着？去挑战那种“你一直在做错事”的假设，并问问自己：“如果别人做了这件事，我会觉得他们需要为此道歉吗？”因为答案往往是百分之百不会，但当对象是我们自己时，我们却往往扮演着更严厉、更苛刻的批评者。如果你道歉是为了避免负面反应，那就问问自己：“如果我此刻不道歉，可能发生的现实中最糟糕的结果是什么？”
outcome? That could happen if I don't say sorry right now. Often, the catastrophic scenario we build up in our heads, it is far more dramatic than what is actually going to fold. Maybe someone will be mildly inconvenienced for a moment. Or they might not even notice. Also, you're inconveniencing yourself by saying sorry. Why do you deserve to be inconvenienced more than they deserve to be inconvenienced? People are okay. People will tell you if they're upset. People are responsible for their own feelings. People are allowed to be annoyed at you and frustrated at you and they will get over it. They will get over it.
通常情况下，我们在脑海中构建灾难性场景，要比实际发生的情况戏剧化得多。也许有人会感到一小会儿的不便，或者他们甚至根本没有注意到。另外，你一直在说对不起，其实也是在给自己制造不便。凭什么你活该遭受更多的不便，而他们却不该？大家都没那么脆弱。如果别人不高兴了，他们会告诉你的。每个人都要为自己的情绪负责。别人有权对你感到恼火和沮丧，而且他们会过去的，他们会过去的。
That is their problem. You're just existing. They're just existing. They aren't entitled to a life that is free of inconvenience and discomfort the same way that you aren't either. And so if they genuinely believe that they are entitled to everyone kind of kissing their ass and making their life feel easy and frictionless and free of frustration, and that's your job,
那是他们的问题。你只是在过你的人生，他们也只是在过他们的人生。他们并没有权利过一种完全没有不便和不适感的生活，正如你也没有一样。因此，如果他们真心认为自己有权让所有人都去奉承他们、让他们的生活变得轻松顺遂、没有任何挫折，而那是你的责任，
not their job to regulate their emotions. That is their problem. I don't know if anyone's ever told you this, but it's not your job to manage everyone else's emotional state 24-7. You don't have the ability to do that. You don't have the time. Finally, really reframe your script, both internally and externally. Instead of thinking, I must apologize, I'm being such a bother,
而不是他们自己去调节情绪的责任，那这就是他们的问题了。我不知道有没有人跟你说过，全天候24小时管理所有其他人情绪的状态，根本不是你的工作。你没有这个能力，也没有这个时间。最后，无论是从内心还是在言语上，真正去重新调整你的话术。不要再去想“我必须道歉，我真是个麻烦”，
try reframing it to something like, actually my needs are valid, it's okay to ask for what I need, my perspective is valuable, even if it's different. I'm just as entitled to this space as they are. This isn't about becoming inconsiderate. In fact, I don't think you could ever be inconsiderate, considering where you're coming from, right? A chronic apologiser is never going to turn into someone who is brutally rude because that part of them is always going to be there, kind of.
而是试着把它重新调整为：“其实我的需求是合理的，寻求我需要的东西并没有错；我的观点很有价值，哪怕它与众不同；我和他们一样有权拥有这个空间。”这并不是要变成一个不体贴的人。事实上，考虑到你的出发点，我认为你根本不可能变成一个不体贴的人，对吧？一个习惯性道歉的人永远不会变成一个粗鲁无礼的人，因为他们骨子里的那种特质永远都在。
But it's really about just affirming your right to exist and to express yourself authentically. I also think the power of the pause here is so key. This is your new best friend. Before the sorry automatically tumbles out, take a tiny breath just a second or two, take a pause and decide whether you're going to apologize rather than just letting it come out of your mouth. And if you want to say sorry, try and replace it with a better alternative. Try and swap it out. I'm going to give you some examples here and I'm going to give you a little.
这其实只是关于肯定你生存的权利以及真实表达自我也同样重要。我也觉得这里的“暂停”有着无比强大的力量。这将是你的新挚友。在“对不起”三个字脱口而出之前，花上短短一两秒钟微微喘口气，先暂停一下，然后由你自己来决定是否要道歉，而不是任由它直接从嘴里溜出来。如果你真的很想说抱歉，试着用更好的替代方案来替换它。试着转换一下说法。我在这里会给你一些例子，
bit of a list because I think it's really helpful to have it in your mind, like some examples of what you could say as an alternative. Instead of saying, sorry to bother you when asking for help, try something like, excuse me, do you have a moment? Or when you have a chance, could you help me with this? Or even just a simple like, hi, I have a question. Instead of saying, sorry for the delay in replying, try thanks for your patient. I use this all the time. Like, I have nothing to apologize for if I didn't get to someone's email because I was getting to other people's emails or I was doing other things.
列出一个小清单，因为我认为把这些例子记在心里真的很有帮助，比如你可以用什么话来替代。在请求帮助时，与其说“真不好意思打扰你”，不如试着说：“不好意思，请问你现在有空吗？”或者“等你方便的时候，能帮我看一下这个吗？”甚至可以简单地说一句：“嗨，我有个问题想问。”再比如，与其说“回复不及时，实在抱歉”，不如说“谢谢你的耐心等待”。我经常这么用。如果我因为忙着回复别人的邮件或处理其他事情而没能及时回复某人的邮件，我根本不需要为此道歉。
So saying thank you puts the onus on them and saying, I appreciate you rather than I feel like I've done something wrong. And it really does change the tone to be one that it's a lot more positive. Instead of you having to say sorry and then I'm going to say like, oh no, it's no problem. And you often are saying, oh yeah, no, but actually I'm really. sorry, it's like, no, thank you. And they say, yeah, you're very welcome. You know, it's a much nicer, more positive interaction. Instead of saying, sorry to interrupt or sorry, can I just say something
所以说一声“谢谢你”，就把主动权交给了对方，表达的是“我很感激你”而不是“我觉得自己做错了什么”。这确实能把语气变得积极得多。与其由你来说抱歉，然后对方说“噢不，没关系”，而你往往又会接一句“噢对，不过我其实真的很抱歉”——不如换成你说“谢谢”，然后对方回答“不客气”。你知道的，这是一个美好得多的积极互动。在开会、工作或与朋友相处时，与其说“不好意思打扰一下”或者“对不起，我能说句话吗”，
in a meeting or at work or with friends, try, I actually have a thought on that. Or could I actually add something here? Or just simply waiting for a natural pause in the conversation. When someone bumps into you, this is a classic, instead of automatically saying sorry, try saying nothing or a simple, oh, excuse me, if you genuinely need to pass or if, you know, they've bumped into you and you're like, you have to say sorry to me, dude, come on, your turn. I hate doing this. Like, I hate when I do this. I had to call myself out on this the other day. I had my dog, Talu, at the dog park. And someone's dog, like, ran up and, like, was barking at her and trying to basically, like, attack her.
不如试着说：“关于这一点，我其实有个想法。”或者“我能在这里补充一点吗？”再或者，干脆安静地等待谈话中的一个自然停顿。当有人撞到你时——这是一个经典场景——与其下意识地道歉，不如试着什么都不说，或者简单说一句“噢，不好意思”，前提是你确实需要通过，或者如果……你知道的，明明是他们撞了你，你心里却在想：“老兄，你得跟我道歉吧，拜托，轮到你啦。”我讨厌这样。比如，我讨厌自己这样做。前几天我带我的狗狗塔鲁去狗公园时，就不得不反省过自己。当时有只狗突然跑过来，冲着它狂叫，甚至试图攻击它。
And I obviously had full control over her. And she was just looking at me, like, what is this person doing? And the guy, like, comes up and I'm like, oh, sorry, oh, sorry. He didn't say sorry to me once. And yet his dog was off leash and running at mine and making us feel uncomfortable. He just looked at me and was like, oh, no worries. and I left that interaction just being like, what just happened? Like, this guy probably thinks he's done nothing wrong.
而我的狗狗显然在我的完全控制之下。它只是看着我，仿佛在说：“这人在干嘛？”然后那个狗主人慢悠悠走过来，而我却脱口而出：“噢，对不起，噢，对不起。”他一整句抱歉都没对我说过。然而，明明是他的狗没拴绳、朝我的狗冲过来、让我们感到不舒服。他只是看着我，说了句“噢，没事”。而我离开那个互动时却在想：“刚才发生了什么？这家伙可能觉得自己一点错都没有。”
And I feel really terrible. And I feel like, I don't know, I just felt like he had so much power over me in that situation because I said, sorry. I wish I'd said something else, but that's what we're talking about here today. Finally, instead of saying something like, sorry for rambling or sorry for taking up your time, which is a big one, I think we often feel like we can't take a, up as much verbal space as other people. We need to be quiet. If you're someone who is constantly thinking, like, are we talking the same amount? Is that person talking as much as I am? And should I talk
而我却觉得自己糟透了。我觉得……我不知道，我只觉得在那场互动中他占据了绝对的掌控权，仅仅因为我说了声“对不起”。我真希望自己当时换个说法，但这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。最后，与其说类似“抱歉我废话太多了”或者“抱歉占用了你的时间”这样的话——这是一个很常见的情况，我认为我们经常觉得自己不该占用和别人一样多的言语空间，我们需要保持安静。如果你总是忍不住去想：“我们俩说话的份额一样吗？那个人说的话和我一样多吗？我是不是应该少说点？”
less? This one's for you. Instead, I want you to try saying, thank you so much for listening, or thanks for letting me share that. Again, it's that same switch. Instead of feeling like you were at a deficit, make the other person feel like they're at an addition. Like, they've been a good person. make them feel like they're being celebrated for being so nice and giving you space. It's also super helpful to practice saying no to things you don't want to do or you just can't do without feeling like you have to give an explanation. I have been trying to do this more. I'm getting better at it.
那这段话就是专门对你说的。相反，我希望你试着说：“非常感谢你听我倾听，”或者“谢谢你让我分享这些。”同样的，这又是一个身份转换。与其觉得自己处于亏欠状态，不如让对方觉得他们是在做加法，让他们觉得自己是个好人。让对方为自己的善良和为你提供交流空间而感到被赞赏。学会对那些你不想做或根本做不到的事情说“不”，而且不需要为此绞尽脑汁地解释，这也是超级有帮助的。我一直在努力这么做，而且我越来越擅长了。
I used to find that if I was canceling plans, I'd have to be like, I'm so sorry I'm canceling plans. Actually, like there's been mucus coming out of my nose for the last 12 hours. And I promise I'm sick. Like, do you want a photo? Like, I can give you an explanation and people would be like, Like if you're sick, you're sick, like it's fine. So simply just saying like, I can't make it, but thank you for the invitation.
我过去常常觉得，如果我要取消行程，我就必须解释：“我真的太抱歉了，我得取消计划。实际上，过去12小时里我的鼻涕一直流个不停，我发誓我是真的生病了。你想看照片吗？我可以给你一个解释。”而人们其实只会说：“行吧，既然你生病了，那就算了。”所以，只要简单地说一句“我抽不出时间，不过谢谢你的邀请”，
Or I don't really have the time right now. Or no, sorry, can't make it that night is often enough. You don't owe everyone a detailed excuse cushioned with sorries. Maybe you owe a close friend that. If you can't work and your boss is asking you to do an extra shift, sorry, I can't make it. You don't need to give them an excuse. They are not any more entitled to your time than you are. if someone, you know, want something from you, like, really late at night.
或者“我这会儿实在没空”，或者“不行啊，抱歉，那天晚上我过不去”，通常这就足够了。你并不欠所有人一个用各种“抱歉”包裹着的详细借口。也许对于挚友，你确实需要解释。但如果无法工作，而老板要求你加班，你只要说“抱歉，我做不到”就行了。你不需要给他们编造借口。他们并不比你更有权支配你的时间。如果有人在深夜想要你帮个忙，
Like, you don't actually have to do it for them. Your whole life does not exist to make someone else's life more convenient. No is a complete sentence. No is a complete sentence. As abrupt and cold as it might initially feel, a philosophy that I've been trying to live by more and more, and it's going to sound weird, is I'm allowed to be an asshole. Sometimes you have to be the asshole
其实你根本不必满足他们。你的人生不是为了让别人的生活更方便而存在的。“不”是一个完整的句子。“不”是一个完整的句子。尽管一开始可能会让人觉得生硬而冷酷，但我一直在努力践行的一种人生哲学——听起来可能会有点奇怪——那就是：我允许自己当一个混蛋。有时你就是得当那个混蛋，
Sometimes you have to be the one that's going to stand up for yourself and piss people off It's okay, like they'll get over it I don't know when people do it to me, I get over it Actually I admire them more You're allowed to be the asshole In fact, it's a good thing You'll get more for yourself, you'll get more done, You'll have more time for yourself
有时你就是得做那个挺身而出、惹恼别人的人。没关系的，他们会过去的。我不知道，当别人对我这么做时，我也能过去。实际上，我反而更钦佩他们。你完全可以当一个混蛋。事实上，这是一件好事。你会为自己争取到更多权益，你会做成更多事，你也会为自己留出更多时间。
You'll feel more assertive and you'll feel like you are more capable I think over time creating these changes in just how simple everyday interactions can really reaffirm a sense of self-worth, a sense of value, a sense that you can trust yourself, you can stand up for yourself, you are your own protector, you have something to say, and it makes you feel more authentic. I think we all hope for a time when we can walk into a conversation and say, I'm here, this is what I want to say, and if you don't agree with it or if it's something that annoys you, like, I don't really care. I'm not even thinking about your reaction. That's really
你会觉得自己更加自信，并且觉得自已更有能力。我认为，随着时间的推移，在简单日常互动的点滴中做出这些改变，真的能够重塑你的自尊感、价值感，让你觉得你可以信任自己、可以为自己挺身而出、你是自己的守护者、你有话要说，这会让你感觉自己更加真实。我想我们都期待着这样一天的到来：我们可以走进一场对话，自信地说：“我来了，这就是我想说的；如果你不同意，或者如果你觉得被冒犯了，其实我并不太在乎，我甚至压根没去想你的反应。”这才是我们
what we're all aiming for, a life in which we are considerate of other people, but we also consider ourselves as being just as important in those interactions and conversations as them. Quiet confidence is perhaps the best way to put it. Quiet confidence and self-assurance. Okay, we're going to take a short break, give you some thinking space. But when we return, we have some listener questions from you all about some of the more specific parts about chronic apologizing you are answered. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
所有人真正追求的目标——一种既体谅他人，但同时也把我们自己在这些互动和对话中的重要性看得跟对方一样重的人生。内敛的自信，或许是最好的表达方式。内敛的自信与笃定。好了，我们要稍微休息一下，留点时间让大家思考。但当我们回来时，我们将解答各位听众关于习惯性道歉更具体的一些问题。所以，请继续收听。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家拨开那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学迷雾。我们曾经深信植物油天生具有炎症性，但我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是 Apple Podcasts、iHeartRadio App 或你获取播客的任何地方，搜索 T-W-O-P-E-R-C-E-N-T。任何男士都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《闺蜜》的新一季中，天哪，这竟然是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends.
我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应得的惩罚。收听《闺蜜》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever. you got your podcast. You remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和莉莉·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个时代，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈 80 年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我一整天都在聊快克都没问题，但只是想让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month,
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐。
don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世上当一个好人很重要吗？你当好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. Heart Radio app, search learn the hard way and listen now.
而且那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。加入我和卡尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你的免费 iHeart Radio 应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。
The listener questions for this topic were incredible. They were so, so good. For those of you who don't know, perhaps like a week or two before an episode goes live, I jump on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and ask if you guys have any specific questions, dilemmas, stories about any of our upcoming topics. Make sure you're following me over there so you can participate in future episodes, but the question for this week were super good. Let's start with this one. I'm a midwife and some of my clients do this. How can I help? This is kind of linked to a more general
这个话题的听众提问简直不可思议。它们太棒了。对于那些不知道的人来说，可能在一集节目上线前的一两周，我会登录 Instagram 上的“That Psychology Podcast”，询问你们对我们即将讨论的话题是否有任何具体的问题、困境或故事。确保你在那里关注了我，以便参与未来的节目，但本周的问题真的超级好。让我们从这个开始。我是一名助产士，我的一些客户会这样做。我该如何帮助？这有点类似于一个更普遍的
question that was asked a lot. How can I help a friend, a family member, a partner who is constantly apologizing? I think it's by simply asking them, what do you think you need to be sorry about? And if they don't really have an answer, just let that sink in for them. You know, if they say, I'm so sorry, like, I'm so sorry for asking for this. I'm so sorry for doing that. I'm so sorry for, you know, being too needy. Just say, why do you need to apologize? And really, like, get them to answer you because often they'll realize that they don't, and that can create a lot of big mental shifts for them. I think if they continue to say it, you can also say something like, well, no, I'm not annoyed by that. I wasn't hurt by that. I didn't even notice that.
被问得很多的问题。我该如何帮助一个经常道歉的朋友、家庭成员或伴侣？我想这很简单，只要问他们：“你觉得你需要为什么道歉？”如果他们真的说不出答案，就让他们细细体会一下。你知道，如果他们说：“我很抱歉，比如，我很抱歉问这个。我很抱歉做了那个。我很抱歉，你知道的，表现得太需要人照顾了。”只需说：“你为什么需要道歉？”并真正让他们回答你，因为通常他们会意识到自己其实并不需要，这可以为他们带来很多重大的心理转变。我想如果他们继续说，你也可以说类似的话：“哦，不，我没有因此烦恼。我没有被伤害到。我甚至都没注意到那件事。”
That didn't impact me. So you don't need to apologize. instead of just saying, you know, it's fine or you did nothing wrong, realize that they're looking for reassurance and they're looking for safety. So just be soft, be warm, be gentle, validate them, make sure that they know that, you know, you're not upset at them, that they don't have to continue apologizing that they are allowed to ask for as much or as little as they want, especially with this first person who asked that question being a midwife, like they should be able to ask for whatever they want if they're giving birth.
那没有对我产生影响。所以你不需要道歉。”而不是只说“你知道的，没关系”或“你没有做错任何事”，要意识到他们是在寻求安慰和安全感。所以要温柔、温暖、体贴，肯定他们，让他们知道，你知道的，你并没有生他们的气，他们不必继续道歉，他们可以根据自己的意愿要求或多或少的东西，特别是问这个问题的第一个人是一名助产士，如果她们正在分娩，她们应该能够要求她们想要的任何东西。
And also just realize that really it is safety seeking. So the more you create like a warm environment for them where you ask them or you anticipate things that they're going to ask for so they don't feel like they have to ask for them, the more that they will hopefully say it a little bit less. Also send them this episode, maybe not for if you're the midwife with the clients, you might not see them enough to send them this episode, but for a friend or a family member or someone that you know, I think listening to someone else talk about it is quite validating
并且也要意识到，这实际上是在寻求安全感。因此，你为他们营造的温暖环境越多，你主动询问或预判他们会要求的东西，这样他们就不会觉得必须开口索取，他们希望就会少说一点。另外，把这一集发给他们，也许不适用于你作为助产士面对客户的情况，你可能见他们不够多，无法发这一集，但对于朋友、家人或你认识的人，我认为听别人谈论这个话题具有相当大的肯定作用，
and understanding where it comes from and how to stop doing it, you know, for themselves is super, super important. This next question, is there an opposite of this, like someone who never apologizes? Oh yes, absolutely there is. I used to date someone like this. I know firsthand that there are people like this. And honestly, now that I think about it,
并且了解它从何而来以及如何停止这样做，对他们自己来说是超级超级重要的。下一个问题，有没有与此相反的情况，比如从不道歉的人？哦，是的，绝对有。我以前约会过这样的人。我亲身知道有这样的人。老实说，现在回想起来，
maybe that's where my chronic apologizing came from because I so desperately was like waiting for him to apologize for things. Maybe I thought that if I said it enough times, he would kind of get it. Like, you did something bad. You need to say sorry. I think these people don't say sorry because they, I think it's just ego.
也许这就是我习惯性道歉的来源，因为我非常绝望地等待他为某些事情道歉。也许我想如果我说得够多，他大概就会明白了。比如，你做错了事。你需要说对不起。我认为这些人不说对不起是因为他们，我认为这只是自负。
I think they genuinely don't believe that they have anything to be sorry for. I think they're quite arrogant. I think they feel quite entitled. I also just think that maybe it's because they were raised by people who were like, you know, very much you are the most important person. You are the center of the universe. If other people don't like your behavior, that's their bad luck. I see this a lot with people like the older they get as well.
我认为他们真诚地不认为自己有什么需要道歉的。我认为他们相当傲慢。我认为他们觉得理所当然。我还认为，也许是因为他们是由这样的人抚养长大的：“你知道的，你绝对是最重要的人。你是宇宙的中心。如果其他人不喜欢你的行为，那是他们倒霉。”我发现随着人们年龄的增长，这种情况也经常出现。
It's like, yes, you get more confident and self-assured as you get older, but you also tend to give less of a shit about what other people think. And the thing that we're really trying to nail in here is that, you know, the opposite of chronic apologising isn't being completely inconsiderate and rude. Actually, we want to find that balance where it's like you care equally about someone else as you, as much as you do yourself, perhaps you care about yourself a little bit more, but there is still caring compassion there. So yeah, there are definitely people who never apologize. And the most frustrating thing about it is that these are the kind of people who never realized why it's a problem.
就像是，随着年龄的增长，你确实会变得更自信、更坚定，但你也往往会更不在乎别人的看法。而我们真正想要确立的一点是，你知道的，习惯性道歉的反面并不是完全漠不关心和粗鲁。实际上，我们想要找到那种平衡，就像你关心别人和关心自己一样多，也许你更关心自己一点点，但其中仍然有关心和同理心。所以，是的，确实有些人从不道歉。而最令人沮丧的是，这类人从不明白为什么这是一个问题。
And it's just stubbornness, really. It's stubbornness and it's ego and, yeah, it's definitely not a good habit. Is there a link to a religious upbringing? I was raised Catholic and I feel like that is a large reason why I constantly need to say sorry. I think with Catholicism in particular, there's a real culture of repentance, right? And there's a culture of guilt and sense. saying sorry for things that you actually don't, that you didn't do wrong or that you don't need
这其实只是固执。这是固执，是自负，而且，是的，这绝对不是一个好习惯。这与宗教背景有联系吗？我是在天主教家庭长大的，我觉得这是我不断需要说对不起的一个重要原因。我认为特别是天主教，有一种真正的忏悔文化，对吧？还有一种负罪感和罪恶感的文化。为那些你实际上并没有做错、或者你不需要
to be sorry for and showing God that you're apologetic and accepting mercy and accepting grace. So definitely there is a link to a religious upbringing 100%. I often find that people who have experienced very strict religious, upbringings and strict religious environments often experience a lot of guilt around taking up space or being special. They experience a lot more guilt around mistakes. It's something that, you know, yes, mistakes are normal and they're natural and they happen and everyone makes them, but for them, it feels like something that they need to be punished for, they need to repent for. So if that was how you were raised, you know, there's a lot of guilt there and I think chronic apologizing is probably a lot
道歉的事情说对不起，向上帝表达你的悔意，并接受怜悯和恩典。所以宗教背景绝对有100%的联系。我经常发现，经历过非常严格的宗教背景和严格的宗教环境的人，在占用空间或表现得与众不同时，往往会经历很多负罪感。他们对错误感到更多的内疚。这是那种，你知道的，是的，错误是正常的、自然的、会发生的，每个人都会犯，但对他们来说，这感觉像是他们需要受到惩罚、需要忏悔的事情。所以如果那是你成长的方式，你知道，那里有很多负罪感，我认为习惯性道歉可能会更
more common. I'd love to see how certain religions relate to, yeah, relate to this habit because it would be very fascinating. It'd be a very fascinating way of, I think it would bring about a whole new dimension of this discussion as well. This is our fourth question. I think our final question for today, what are some other ways to convey empathy or sympathy without saying sorry, such as when a friend experiences a loss or someone tells you something sad has happened to them, such as a parent, or a loved one dying. This is something I struggle with a lot. I think a lot of us do, our immediate instinct when someone says,
普遍得多。我很想看看某些宗教是如何与这种习惯产生联系的，因为这将是非常迷人的。这将是一种非常迷人的方式，我认为它也会为这场讨论带来一个全新的维度。这是我们的第四个问题。我想也是我们今天的最后一个问题，在不说对不起的情况下，有哪些其他方式可以传达共情或同情？比如当朋友经历亲人离世，或者有人告诉你发生了让他们难过的事，比如父母或爱人去世。这是我非常纠结的一点。我想我们很多人也是，当有人说时，我们的第一直觉就是：
oh, you know, my mama passed away or my dog passed away, or this terrible thing happened to me is to say, I'm so sorry. And then they say, what are you sorry for? And then you feel really awkward. And you wish that you'd said something better. So say this instead. That is so difficult.
“哦，你知道的，我妈妈去世了”或者“我的狗去世了”，或者“这件糟糕的事情发生在我身上”，然后就要说“我很抱歉”。然后他们会说：“你抱歉什么？”然后你就会感到非常尴尬。你会希望自己当时说过更好的一些话。所以，改用这样说：那太艰难了。
And you have all my love right now. And any help that you need, I'm here to offer it. You can also just ask a question as a response. That's so awful, but how are you feeling? Is there anything I can do? Or offer support? You know, I can't imagine what you're going through. I can come over and cook dinner for you.
你现在拥有我全部的爱。任何你需要帮助的地方，我都随时准备提供。你也可以直接问一个问题作为回应。那太糟糕了，但你现在感觉怎么样？有什么我可以做的吗？或者提供支持？你知道的，我无法想象你正在经历什么。我可以过来为你煮晚饭。
I can drive you to that appointment. I can do anything that you need me to do. I love you. I care about you. Often the reason we say I'm sorry is because it's the easiest way in our brains to express empathy. Yes, and often it's just shock. You know, we're not taught how to manage grief. We're not taught how to have hard conversations.
我可以开车送你去那个预约。我可以做任何你需要我做的事。我爱你。我关心你。通常我们说“我很抱歉”是因为这是我们大脑中表达同理心最简单的方式。是的，通常这只是一种震惊。你知道的，我们没有被教导如何应对悲伤。我们没有被教导如何进行艰难的对话。
We're not taught as a society the right thing to say. So it is okay if you don't say the right thing. I think it's also okay to say, I'm sorry as a first instinct, but match that I'm sorry by going deeper and by offering something more. Really try and think about what you would want to hear, what you would need in that situation. And that is the best thing that you can say. That is the best thing that you can offer them.
社会没有教导我们该说正确的话。所以，如果你没有说对的话也没关系。我认为作为第一直觉说“我很抱歉”也是可以接受的，但要把这个“我很抱歉”付诸更深的行动，并提供更多实质性的东西。真正去思考你想听到什么，你在那种情况下需要什么。那是你能说的最好的一句话。那是你能提供给他们的最好的东西。
Also, you know, just asking people, what do you need from me? What can I do to help you is also so invaluable. But yeah, it's a hard thing. I feel like I do this a lot. My instinct is always to say, I'm so sorry. And then it's like, oh, but yeah, but what am I sorry for? You know, I didn't do anything to cause this. But I think, again, I'm sorry is a verbal filler.
另外，你知道的，直接问人们：“你需要我做什么？我能做什么来帮到你？”也是极其宝贵的。但是，是的，这是一件难事。我觉得我经常这样做。我的直觉总是说：“我很抱歉。”然后就会想：“哦，但是，是的，但我为什么要道歉呢？你知道的，我没有做任何导致这一切的事。”但我认为，再次说明，“我很抱歉”只是一种口头禅。
It is a blanket term that we use in so many other situations where we aren't actually apologizing. Remember, you know, if you are a chronic apologizer, it's not something that you need to feel ashamed of. That shame will perhaps only make it worse. I just think it's something you need to understand that you do and really trace back to a reason behind why you do it. And then I want you to really keep focused on those alternatives. And remember that critical thing I said around the middle of this episode. If someone is upset at you, if someone is frustrated at you, if you inconvenience someone, that's not necessarily your problem. People inconvenience you all the time without you realizing it and you let them. People are rude all the time without having to
这是一个我们在许多其他并未真正道歉的情况下使用的泛称。记住，你知道的，如果你是一个习惯性道歉的人，这并不是一件需要感到羞耻的事。这种羞耻感可能只会让情况变得更糟。我只是觉得你需要明白这是你在做的事，并真正追溯到你这样做的原因。然后我希望你真正专注于那些替代方案。并记住我在本集节目中间说过的那句关键的话。如果有人对你不满，如果有人对你感到沮丧，如果你给别人带来了不便，那不一定是你的问题。人们一直在给你带来不便而你却没有意识到，并且你原谅了他们。人们一直在无礼而不需要
say sorry. There are some really terrible people in this world. You are not one of them. So you don't have to constantly apologize for your presence and for your existence for anything that you say or don't say like you're doing a great job other people have to be responsible for their emotions you cannot constantly monitor them for them and trust that if they're frustrated at you if they're mad it's their responsibility to say something but i really do hope this episode has unpacked some of this for you i know it was kind of a long one make sure again to listen to mantra if you liked this episode if you like the psychology of your 20s there are so much more over there that i think you will enjoy. And if you've made it this far, hello, hi, how are you? Thank you for listening. Our emoji for this
说对不起。这个世界上有一些非常糟糕的人。你不是其中之一。所以你不必为你的存在、为你的生存、为你所说或不说的话不断地道歉，就像你做得很好一样。其他人必须对他们的情绪负责，你不能时刻替他们监测，并且要相信，如果他们对你不满，如果他们生气了，那是他们自己的责任去说出来。但我真的希望这一集能为你解开其中的一些谜团。我知道这期节目有点长，如果你喜欢这一集，如果你喜欢《The Psychology of Your 20s》，请确保再次收听 Mantra，那里还有很多你会喜欢的内容。如果你能听到这里，你好，嗨，最近怎么样？感谢收听。我们这周的
week, I think is an owl. So if you want to show me down in the comments that you have listened as far as you have, an owl is the way to go. Make sure that you are following along on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, IHeartRadio. Wherever you were listening, share this episode with a friend who you think may enjoy it. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Remember, you don't need to apologize for simply taking up space. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
表情符号，我认为是一只猫头鹰。所以如果你想在评论区向我展示你听到了这里，猫头鹰就是最好的选择。确保你在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts、iHeartRadio 上关注我们。无论你在哪里收听，把这一集分享给你认为会喜欢的朋友。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。记住，你不需要仅仅为了占用空间而道歉。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方的 TWO%。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84 年对我意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild. I mean, it was a wild year.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每集我们会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理清我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回首往事”。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《吃一堑长一智》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《吃一堑长一智》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对应有的惩罚。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。